renversé le 1er février dernier aung san
suu kyi est depuis assigné à résidence
dans un lieu tenu secret ce mardi les
militaires au pouvoir ont tenu à
rassurer le monde entier sur l'état de
santé de l'ancien président de facto les
gardons dow jones uci et you win min
dans un endroit plus sûr pour leur
sécurité
ils sont en bonne santé ce n'est pas
comme si elle avait été arrêtée
ils sont logés chez eux nous allons
continuer à nous conformer à la loi
nous allons procéder qui conformément à
la loi
je tiens à dire que nous n'irons pas au
delà de la loi
poursuivi pour avoir importé
illégalement des talkie walkie of sound
souci était de nouveau convoquée au
tribunal ce mardi l'ex dirigeant de 75
ans a été mise en examen pour un nouveau
chef d'inculpation
une nouvelle audience aura lieu le 1er
mars
hanks en sushi est poursuivi pour un
nouveau dossier
elle a été enquêtés en application de la
sous section 8 de la loi sur les
exportations et les importations et
aussi de la section 25 de la loi sur la
gestion des catastrophes naturelles
mobilisés et déterminés les birmans
continuent quant à eux de manifester
dans tout le pays
a rangoon des moines bouddhistes se
revendiquant de la révolution du safran
de 2007 ont défilé devant la
représentation locale des nations unies
dans la capitale naypyidaw des birmans
se sont réunis devant le tribunal pour
appeler à la libération d'aung san suu
kyi
[Musique]
nous ne voulons pas d'une dictature
militaire nous devrons donc nous battre
contre eux jusqu'à ce qu'il démissionne
cela fait longtemps que nous ne voulions
pas de jantes nous ainsi que nos parents
avaient beaucoup souffert à cause d'eux
nous ne voulons pas d'eux nous
conviennent et l'ouganda si nous voulons
qu on sound succi soit libéré c'est
parce qu'elle est une dirigeants de
notre pays
elle traite tout le monde équitable
membres elle soutient le bon camp c'est
une mère pour tout le pays
dans le même temps la répression
militaire grandit dans le pays les tanks
sont de sortie et l'armée recours à des
tirs de balles en caoutchouc et à balles
réelles contre les protestataires
d'importantes coupures d'internet ont
été signalées pour la deuxième nuit
consécutive l'armée birmane nie toute
implication de pékin dans ces
interruptions de réseaux internet
l'ambassadeur chinois a de son côté
déclaré que la situation en birmanie
n'est pas je cite ce que la chine
voudrait voir